こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さんは
ポケカご存知でしょうかポケカ僕も何回か
動画でやったことあるんですけども
ポケモンカードの略でございます大人気
ゲームポケットモンスターのカードゲーム
バージョンってことでポケモンがカードに
なっててポケモン同士をカードで戦わせ
るっていうやつですねめちゃくちゃ面白い
んですけども最近
人気すぎてえぐい人気が本当にすごいね
ポケカが最近発売した診断のパックなんて
もう買えなくて何でしたっけなんか地中
生産になったんだっけ生産ってもう需要が
ありすぎてもうみんな欲しくなっちゃっ
てるぐらい本当に手に入らない大人気
ポケモンカードゲームもちろんコレクター
として集める人もいるんですけどもポケ
カって基本的にそのバトル60枚カードを
集めてデッキを作って戦うんですけれども
人気だけじゃなくてめちゃくちゃ高い
カードとかあるんですよ同じ効果同じ
カードなのになんかキラキラしてるからし
てないかだけですごい値段が変わったり
そのポケカって歴史が長いから希少価値が
全然違うんですよ同じカードでも
ってことはいいよってことはこんな人気
かつ高い方は高い一番高いデッキって何な
んだろうそして何円になるのか気になり
まして私はじめしゃちょー
作りました
[音楽]
よくよく頑張ったえらいえらいポケット
詳しい人に聞いてちゃんと戦えるしっかり
と強くて一番高いデッキ作りました俺も
まだねちゃんと計算してないんですけども
何円になるんだろう本当に呼べないんです
けどもただ一つだけわかることがあります
高い
はいというわけで俺が頑張って作った今の
ポケカで一番金額が高いでこちらです
60枚ですまあみんな言いたいことわかり
ません60番にしてはちょっとでかくない
みたいなそんなに暑いかカード60枚ごと
切って思うかもしれませんがこれで
ちゃんと60枚のデッキしか入ってません
開けてみます
[音楽]
金額が金額だったから戦ってるとカードが
ちょっと傷んだりするから絶対傷まない
ために僕こういう感じでカード1枚1枚
完璧に保存しました透明な激化型スリーブ
というのかなこれスリーブてこれで対戦し
ちゃだめなんだろうな普通は俺はします
けど多分しちゃダメですけどもこういう
感じでしっかりデッキ60枚準備させて
もらいました一応ルールとしてはポケモン
カード色んなレギュレーションルールが
あるんですけども今回ですねスタンダード
レギュレーション一番メジャーなルールで
今の環境で強いちゃんと戦える勝つ金額が
最強というルールで作らせてもらいました
ちょっと出してみようと思います
よしよしよしよしよし出た出た出たはい皆
さんこれがポケカ最高金額のデッキです
あのね高いカードってその対戦とかで使わ
ないのよ傷つけたくないからただ高くても
対戦可能にするにはもう俺こうするしか
なくてちょっとあの若干厚みが出てしまっ
たんですけどこれご了承ください普通の
デックと比べてもこのサイズの差ですただ
それだけ貴重っていうことですよさあ気に
なるこのデッキのお値段見ていきましょう
か
[音楽]
結構変動的なんですよ生き物なんですカー
ドってどんどん新しいカードとかパックが
出ますとそうすると強いデッキがどんどん
変わりつつあるから強さと
希少価値とかカードのかっこよさ可愛さと
かもう常にそれの変動するからこのデッキ
もね今は一番高いけど何年後かに一番高い
とは限らないの逆にめちゃくちゃ高くなり
続けるかもしれないだから現段階の価値と
いうことだけ皆さんちょっと覚えておいて
くださいで金額はポケカをネット販売して
いる
サイトを基準に調べさせてもらいます
サイトにもよりますけどもまあマートを
外れた金額には絶対せずにこのデッキの
値段調べていきたいと思います最初の
カードはこちらバトルVIPパスこれねー
光ってないでしょ何にも光ってないんです
けども
めっちゃ高いのよまずバトルピッパス4枚
これはねもうね強いデッキには絶対入って
ますから入れました
[音楽]
光ってないのに1枚
2,280円このチケット1枚で
2280円えーそれだけ強いんだとなんか
手に入りにくいのよ今まだボケがやってる
人は何のデッキかわからないでしょそれ
くらいねこれはね当たり前に入ってるか
もうちょっと当たり前ゾーン続きますよ次
はこちらネストボールネストボールの
ちょっと
古いパックに入ってたネストボールの
URっていう光り方をしているカードです
[音楽]
ビビるぜ調べます
この型番のネストボール
37,800円です
これもね必須級なのよ基本的には絶対入っ
てるような誰しもが持ってる使うカードな
んですけどもこの金色のこの向きのネスト
ボールが高いんだって3万7800円が
4枚です
[音楽]
この時点でやばいこの時点でやばいよ
37800円が4枚続いてはこちら
ハイパーボールこれも普通にどんなデッキ
にでも入ってるようなよく見るカーブです
よただこの光り方とこのハイパーボールが
高いんです値段調べましょう
えマジでこれ
キモ
い失礼しましたいい意味でですいい意味で
キモいなと思いましたこちらのハイパー
ボール1枚
42,800円ですこのハイパーボールが
[音楽]
4枚あります
この時点でやばいよ今んとこバトルと
ハイパーボール当たり前に必須系のカード
を3種類紹介しただけよこの次のカードで
多分デッキ分かります次はこちらはい
ゲノセクトvsARスペシャルアートレア
ですこれでもポケカ好きな人はわかる
でしょう何のデッキか基本セクトVって
いう幻のポケモンですね幻のポケモン
ゲノセクトのなんか可愛いおちゃらけてる
イラストになりますはい
そうでもないやっぱバグってるもう感覚が
バグってるすいませんえ俺がおかしいのか
な
3300円です3300円が4枚です
高いよ1枚3000円超えてるカードって
次これで何の出来かわかりますこちら
幻のポケモン
ミュウミュウVというカードのスペシャル
アートレアSARっていうポケモンが人気
だしイラストめっちゃ可愛いんですよもう
対戦でも強いし見た目もかわいいっていう
一応現状ね色んなデッキがあるんですけど
も
ニューVデッキっていうデッキがね
頑張れば一番高くなることが分かりました
値段調べていきますさあ怖い
[音楽]
そこそこ高い1枚
14000円でしたでこれはもうこの
デッキの新宿にあるカードなので
UVが4枚4枚ありますそして
UVが来たということは進化しますこちら
ミュウVMAXのスペシャルアートレア
みんな見てこれこんな可愛いけどあって
ええんか巨大マックスした大きなミュウが
ドカーンと書いてある笑顔のイラストです
これが結構高いんですよ調べます
こんな高いの
在庫も少ないからかなわかんないけど
6万5000円ですね6万5000円です
イラストも可愛いからっていうのもあるん
でしょうけど6万5000もせんの俺それ
4枚あるよなんか3枚入ってるデッキも
多いんですけどもあの僕はこれをこれし
たくて4枚にさせていただいてます
6万5000円でしたもう僕は怖いですよ
なんかね
UVっていうカードとかUVMAXって他
のイラストとかレアリティもあるんです
けどもこのスペシャルアートレアっていう
のがねやけに高いのでレアだから全然数も
ないし
[音楽]
まだ全然序の口ですあとこれだけあります
から見ていきましょう続いてはこちらまた
光ってない大丈夫こんなの本当に高いの
なんか安そうじゃない
ポケモンのなんかロボットになってる
カードですね何これこんなの入れちゃい
ますはじめ値段つくのって思うじゃない
ですか調べますね大丈夫本当に俺が心配に
なってきたわねな
5000円
そんなまだ高いんだなんかねやばい時1枚
1万円近く行ってたんですけど今ちょっと
落ち着いてて5000円ぐらいにはなって
ますねウロボ4枚あります次はポケモン
カードには欠かせないエネルギーのカード
ですこちらダブルダブルエネルギーの
金ピカURですこれできないエネルギー4
枚しか入ってないよダブルとアベ
エネルギー4枚です調べますおー
4000円しますこれ4000円もするん
だ
続いてはこちら入部時に欠かせないカード
パワータブレット
に光ってますけどもたかがなんかね
タブレットのおかしいおいおいはじめお前
こんなの大丈夫かたからこんなおかしい
ペッツなのかと調べますねパワー
タブレット
2200円ですパワー食べると2200円
4枚入ってますこんなのお菓子より高い次
はこちらですスタジアムのカードいただき
への雪道
雪のなんかねこんな風景が見たいな綺麗な
イラストだけども何するんでしょうねこの
カード売り切れてるそして
えー6000円ですこれ
UVデッキ入れる人と入れない人いるん
ですけども僕ガッツリ入れてます1枚
6000円のカードが4枚入ってます次は
こちらロストスイーパーなんか物騒な
カードですねロストスイーパーの金ぴか
これも売り切れてるやっぱ強いんかな
ロストセーパーっていうカードが人気なの
かも美品で2500円ですね2500円4
枚あるのでこれで約1万円ぐらいです次の
カードはね結構ポケカやってる人なら絶対
知ってるカードですポケモン入れ替え
はじめポケモン入れ替えは高くないよ
はじめんみんな持ってます違いますこの
ポケモンいるからね金ピカなんですよあと
めっちゃくちゃレアなの3枚持ってます1
枚の値段調べていきますこれみんな引くと
思う絶対使うカードだからこそ高いんです
5万3000円
みんなポケモンイルカに使ってる人いる俺
はねポケモン入れ替えるだけで
5万3000円するのよこれそれがまあ3
枚あります
よく使うカードでもね
リアリティ考えたらこんな高いのよ次は
こちら
穴抜けの紐はいはい皆さん知ってると思い
ますこの穴抜けの紐もよく使います金ピカ
だとどうなってしまうのか
あんなだけどちょっと間違えた入りました
5万5000円
大事にしようあんだけの紐は1枚だけ入っ
てます55000円高かっ金ピカのカード
をたくさん続いてますけどもここで
ちょっと落ち着きましょうはい
友達手帳ミラー仕様でちょっとキラキラし
てますねこんな手帳1枚何円ぐらいするん
でしょうねえっとミラーミラー7300円
友達手帳7300円ですこれね何でこんな
高いかって言うと友達手帳っていうカード
自体は全然ね300円とか200円とかで
売ってるんだよただこの周りがキラキラし
てるミラー仕様の友達手帳がすごいレア
らしくてこんな7000円超えちゃって
るって感じらしいですこれは1枚だけ入っ
てますこっからちょっと落ち着くカード来
ますはい
オドリドリのアートレアこれmuvを守っ
てくれる大事なカード値段はそんなしない
けどもうこれあの俺ふざけてるわけじゃ
ないからね対戦で使って勝てるデッキを
作ってるのでこういうマジなカード対戦用
のカードもちょっと入れてますすいません
ちょっとねしないか戻り鳥
180円ですちょっと
なんかごめんこれで皆さん分かった
でしょうただただ高いデッキを作りたくて
高い方ぶっこんでるわけじゃないんです
ちゃんと強いデッキ作ってます次はこちら
森の封印石これもねそんな高いカードじゃ
ないんですけどとっても強いんですあー
けど結構するな600円とかです600円
のカードもしっかり入ってますはい
ちゃんと連れてきますもちろん金額が高く
するために多少はちょっといじってるけど
ねここからはですねポケモンカードで大事
なサポートっていうトレーナーとか人の
カードが出てきますこれもね高いカードは
とっても高いんですよまずはこちらです
はいボスの指令
榊SRボスのシレっていうカードいろんな
ボスもあるんですけど調べた感じサカキの
ボスの指令が一番高かったかなこれ1枚
1万2800円です次あーあーこれ
ちょっとね若干おしゃれポイントボタンの
スペシャルアートレアですポケモン
スカーレットバイオレットに出てくる
女の子ですねボタンちゃんなかなかエモな
イラストでしょうこれ多分ね入部デッキ
入れてる人そんないないんですけども
たまに役立つから俺入れてますうわー
2万円です
こうするなぁ
可愛いからなぁ残りカードが6枚になり
ました次のカードはこちらはい
セレナ
可愛いでしょうセレナちゃんねーこれはね
純粋にカードも強いんですよとっても強い
んですけどもイラストが可愛いこれね
可愛い女の子のカード
調べていきましょう
[音楽]
でな
5万7800円です
でこれねなんか1枚だけ入れてる人多いん
ですけどもあのちょっと穴僕そのあのこの
これのことを考えると2万になっちゃい
ましたセレナ2枚入ってますさあ残る
カードは4枚4枚なんですけどもこれ4枚
とも同じカードなんですよさあ皆さんに
問題です今のポケカにおいて唯一ナンバー
ワンの値とされているカード何かわかり
ますでしょうかきっとねポケカやってる人
とか知ってると思いますもうなんか有名
すぎてポケカ知らない人も知ってるかも
しれませんこの4枚
のSARスペシャルアトレア4枚です
[音楽]
ちょっとね皆さんこのなんじゃも
スペシャルアートレアというカード
びっくりしますよまず見た目見てみよう
こんなかわいいことある最高金額狙うとし
たらこれは4枚入れるしかないだろうと
いうことで4枚入れましたクレイバースっ
ていうパークから出るんですけども開封し
ても俺当たんなくて
泣く泣く買いました買ったのはあれして
なんかオリーパっていうカードショップで
売ってるパックで奇跡的に当てたのもあり
ますこれで4枚揃いましたよ問題は気に
なる今の値段どれくらいするんだろうね
なんじゃもちゃん今の金額よ動画出てる時
はわかんないけども今
ネットで写ってるやつ見ると
13万8000円です
[音楽]
俺このデッキ使いたくねえよなんかねこれ
確か最初の時20万とか言ってたんです
けどだいぶ落ち着いて今13万8000円
ですねはいというわけで最高金額のデッキ
の値段調べてみました皆さんもう聞いてる
うちに分かったでしょこれやばい多分相当
やばい俺も
こんな引くと思ってなかったただ現段階の
値段なのでどんどん変動すると思います
もっと高くなるし安くなるかもしれません
がこの俺が生きてる今の時間の値段
このデッキ
総額
167万4800円
なんか100万ぐらいはまあ行くとは思っ
てたけどもはるかに凌駕して160万超え
ちゃってるいやー
このデッキと戦いたいやつおるんかすごい
ねポケカは今や
頑張ればよ本当に何もできるし多分これ
リアリティー選ばなかったら全然
遥かに安い値段でいけると思うんですよ
はいというわけで
史上最高金額のデッキできたわけなんです
けどもどうせ戦えるんだったら
[音楽]
戦ってみたいと思いまして後輩とポケカで
ちょっとバトルするんですけどもそいつは
俺がこの最高金額の作ったこと知らないの
でちょっと知らないまま一線戦ってかざし
て出てくるカード出てくるカード全部
とんでもない金額だったらどういう反応
するのかちょっと見ていきたいと思います
レッツポケモンカード
[音楽]
よろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ますよろしくお願いします
ゴリラパイセンさんになってます
聞かせてもらいますね
よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
はいじゃあお願いします
プロジェクトVです
1枚引きます
使います
ロッドスイーパーと
しますね
はい持ってきますいやーすごいね
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
郵便MAXとすごいなぁ
分かりましたこれでも使います何でも使い
ます何でも使います
[音楽]
じゃあこれで何でも使いますはいはいはい
はい
戻して6枚です
なるほど
[音楽]
です
はい
ありがとうございました
[音楽]